this video is brought to you by
squarespace
it is no secret that i have been a fan
of one wheeling for years i've got about
8 000 miles under my belt at this point
but here's the thing
i've never actually had an opportunity
to see how i stack up against some of
the best writers in the world
until now you see every year future
motion holds an event called race for
the rail and it's a race
to see who is the fastest one-wheel
racer on the planet
and this year i get to go so tomorrow
morning nick and i are jumping on an
airplane we're heading out to utah to go
to some undisclosed
mountain location where the race for the
rail will occur
[Music]
it is thursday 8 a.m we're at lax the
race is on sunday
sunday afternoon so i've got a few days
to do last minute practicing i have been
training my
butt off for the last two straight weeks
i've been one-wheeling at least 10 to 15
miles
every single day the most advanced
trails that i know of just doing them at
like speed runs right
we're an oodah
[Music]
what's that this is a brand new unopened
onewheel xr
this is the board that every single
racer will be using
we are not keeping these things only the
12 riders were allowed in this meeting
so nick was not allowed in there i had
to put my phone in a bag and hand it to
them so i didn't have a phone that whole
time
it was middle school pe class
all over again for me these challenges
will be
team challenges
basically they chose two team captains
and each of those team captains
did a draft i want that person the next
person goes i want this person
back and forth until all the racers have
been chosen i knew the moment this whole
thing started
i was gonna get picked last so i
accepted it i was like all right
pick me last but even that was brought
for me because i was picked
second to last and i can't fault them
for that because you know why
none of them have ever ridden with me
before i'm an actual true wild card in
this race because no one actually knows
my skill set i think i have the skills
to win this race
however so does every single other
person in that room
i'm going up against some of the fastest
racers in the world
dom williams is the reigning race for
the rail champion at just 16 years old
he's already one of the fastest racers
the world has ever seen
dave stewart is the 2018 world champion
almost
as fast as he is humble tahoe dave is a
force to be reckoned with on a one wheel
body harrison is a one wheel trick
master and speed demon
however he has yet to win a championship
and is now hungry for the win
angel cooper was the 2019 women's race
champion and with women and men racing
together this year she's ready to defend
her title
jeff and raquel mccosker are the closest
thing to royalty the onewheel sport has
not only are they both incredibly
talented technical writers and racers
but they founded the float life as a way
to broaden the community and provide
accessories that make the onewheel
even better zoe thomas is scary fast
don't let her young age fool you she
knows how to send it winning the grom
division in 2019.
ory rush takes to the skies higher than
any other writer
when he's not mastering flight fins he's
leaving the other racers in his dust
in addition to the eight racers invited
by future motion four more racers were
selected through a wild card competition
based on public voting
amanda thompson hails from boston and is
well known for shredding trails and
sharing the stoke
jamie checher is actually one of my
oldest one-wheeling friends as the husky
division champ
don't be deceived by his size few people
are faster than him brandon shermeyer is
another la friend of mine he's
all heart and even more skill he's
determined to prove that he's the
fastest writer alive
and then there's me we got chosen onto
teams
so the next two days there are gonna be
three events that we all do as
teams culminating in a fourth event
which will be sunday which would be the
live streamed
full-on race for the rails but i'm
feeling something
maybe it's nerves maybe it's the fact
that this is suddenly real
and i'm actually here
[Music]
okay that is
this is the only time i ever feel
comfortable doing this
yeah that was safe to do probably are
you serious right now
are you doing red come on
not everyone was happy about the fact
that we have to use a completely stock
board i kind of agree with future motion
here i don't think anything is more
fair in a race than everyone using the
exact same
brand new tire let's tally up what i
need to do tonight i need to install
these parts
i need to actually start breaking in the
tire as much as i can in the next hour
or so
and then i just need to get as much
sleep as possible and a healthy
breakfast in the morning
okay all right you got your board nick
you got your board
you got your board i gotta go get my
toast
this is actually it it's actually here
the first event is an hour away
honestly this first race is going to be
very telling so we don't actually know
what this first event is going to be
to have our boards at 50 we're going to
the top of a mountain
just spin the camera around for a moment
look at what i'm looking at right now
the way i earned my spot here was
through public voting and because
of my nature as an online personality
i i wield this form of influence and i
was basically able to utilize that to
get people to vote for me to get me into
the wild card race which
is exactly what future motion had in
mind someone would always have some sort
of social media advantage with the
number of followers they have
but what that means is that i haven't
actually physically earned
my spot here and if i get last place i
will have proven that i didn't deserve
to be here
so i have to make sure i don't get last
place
we got freshies fresh easier yeah you
gotta get it worn down the good stuff
a stock vega tire that comes on a brand
new one wheel has very sharp
corners so it feels like you're
literally riding like a kitchen rolling
pin
it has a lot of turn resistance it's
kind of hard to turn and if you hit a
rock underneath that corner it'll kind
of throw you so what we're all doing
here is we're basically just spinning
out the tire
on the ground to grind down those
corners just kind of like shave off the
corners a little bit
so we have a more rounded profile
these guys know how to do every trick in
the book
i'm trying to do this trick
[Music]
what i want to do is like just kind of
go a little bit and then i
fall off like that right what bodhi was
saying you lean your lower half forward
but your shoulders backwards so it's
like
oh it's hard to commit yeah no you
almost got it
yeah try to do three seconds three
seconds ready
one two three nice
i was gonna say if you weighed like a
little more than me we could both ride a
board
on each foot pad we should still try it
i've ridden doubles on one wheel for a
long time but i've always wanted to ride
doubles with one person on each
foot pad 10 feet just like titanic style
i think today's the day and runs the guy
oh snap come on baby
all right get on and then we got one
no i think this is actually kind of
working
[Music]
oh my god we're doing it for real
this one's for you mom
right let's go fast no oh god this body
wants to go faster
okay okay
yeah oh my gosh so you've never done
that before
nah dude oh wow new unlocked hell yeah
i feel honored that was amazing dude i'm
pumped on that
yeah that's how you start the day dude
hey you guys really just race like that
i think you're like a team at this point
dude
downhill race like that
we're in here from the future spoiler
alert i'm alive
and if you want to know if i win the
race or not well you'll have to wait a
minute here because right now i want to
talk about squarespace
if you're looking to build a website or
online store squarespace is the
all-in-one platform to make it happen
even have the marketing tools and
analytic resources to help optimize your
business for the visitors you already
have and the ones you want to
find with simultaneous posting and
multiple contributors
it's easier than ever to post content
stress free
you can post to multiple different
socials all at the same time or have
different people
all contributing to your brand you can
embed podcasts on your site through
audioblocks or even just set up an email
campaign if you wish too
and best of all you own all of the
content that you put on squarespace
so go to squarespace.com to get your
free trial
and if you're ready to buy a domain name
go to squarespace.com quarter crew
to get 10 off your first domain oh boy
now you know why i have all these holes
in my shirt all right back to the race
this is the official start for the
events for race for the rail 2020. yeah
we're gonna be taking the gondola up to
the top of the mountain it's not running
right now but they're going to turn it
on for us
it's going to be a little intense i've
never done any sort of sport
at a professional level so this is very
new to me and i'm excited it's very cool
i like all the racers they're all cool
people the competitive spirit is strong
at this point it's not about getting
last place it's about not letting my
team down
team skyline for the win okay race is
about to start
team skyline my team we're going first
and the whole idea here is that
everyone on this team has to cross the
finish line for our timer to end
this is first descent you're at 9500
feet
you have about 4 000 feet to go the
first complete team to the bottom
wins we stress that teamwork is going to
be important
we have to build each other up we have
to help each other get down
three two one go
[Applause]
oh there's already carnage they're
they're wasting time
these guys are wasting time
okay this track is extremely gnarly
there are so many loose rocks so i'm
currently in the front
i'm basically scouting the trail finding
good lines and informing everyone behind
me which line
stick inside stick to the right
but we're all trying to go as fast as we
can riders in view
team skyline sticking together it looks
like all six riders are there
here they come crossing the finish line
together this is what it is all about
what is that done
top of that was some of the gnarliest
stuff i have ever done
dude i did a freaking front flip up
there it was just nothing but
giant like knobbly rocks our biggest
mistake
up at the top was trying to bomb it too
fast right off right out of the gate
because once we actually started being a
little bit more careful
we were able to not fall yeah dude that
was so gnarly
i was like i was really glad that we
could uh have the first event
be something where we weren't going full
throttle like eating crap
all over the place find our find our
groove and get in a good state of mind
for the rest of the event
i think i at least earned myself a
little bit of trail cred because these
guys know how gnarly that trail was
and they know that i did it too wow
final time for team skyline was 23
minutes two seconds
so team delaria just has to beat that to
beat us yep looks like dom is there in
the front
he's coming around the corner i knew
like he's about to he's about to cross
the finish line here
now on to the team enduro where riders
will charge
uphill before entering technical single
track
looping around to see there's team at
the exposed finish
we'll see who can take the lead out on
this one and who is the fastest single
track rider
the second race here you can't go full
speed there's going to be all these big
knobbly rocks
in the path so it's going to be a bit
more of a measured ride i'm excited for
this i feel way better about this race
than i did earlier because there are
fewer unknowns
i'm prepared for this now
brendan came riding in hot just set the
best time with eight minutes and 46
seconds
getting those nerves going hey i'm
getting those
it's almost as bad as the ted talk
that was that was worse that was worse
alrighty all righty here comes rent and
three
two one go
this race started off great actually i
was doing really well i was making good
time even too i hadn't fallen off my
board yet
but then the unthinkable happened and my
legs started cramping up
turns out at this altitude my body needs
a lot more oxygen than it was getting
you go down huh i went down and my board
went down the hill
no you had to chase it yep most of it
was fast
i think i was probably trying to go a
little too fast two parts i hit a rock
oh bonk off of it and land on the front
side of the next rock
and just stop my board dead ghost bumps
good knobbly bit's bad
yeah good race man man they weren't
kidding when they called that the
endurance race that was
the gnarliest trail it is so gnarly i
knew about two-thirds of the way through
the race that i wasn't doing well
in fact i actually did better than i
thought i was really hoping for a sub
nine minute
instead i just barely got a sub 10
minute it is what it is i'm still happy
with my time i didn't get last place i
still have two more opportunities to
redo myself i have tomorrow whatever
event that'll end up being we'll find
out like basically as we're starting
and then there's the big race on sunday
the actual official race
all right but for now it's time for
dinner we don't have any events in the
morning
and time to relax for the rest of the
day day one definitely shook my
confidence
about whether or not i deserve to be
here but regardless going into day two
i'm focused and i'm ready to go
okay it is day two and i honestly kind
of feel like i was hit by a truck
i am so sore my thighs are burnt i'm
bruised all over from the multiple
falls i took and it's been just really
crazy
i'm still just coming to terms with not
being as fast as the fastest
few riders maybe they're going to have
us drop off a cliff or something i mean
if we don't know
anything could happen i hear it's ellie
feeling good to go this is it deep
skyline take the back let's go to the
gondola
we got our 13 talent show this
course is fast it's techy it's quick
it's a relay
we'll see what we got team delirium up
2-0 on skyline all right
we just scouted the course i think this
is going to be easier than yesterday by
far
this is a relay race one person goes at
a time and the next person can't start
until
the person behind them finishes team
delirium the other team is going first
on this round
dave sewer just laid down 206 on the
opening lap for skyline that's a very
compelling time
that puts them in the position they need
to win this event and they need it
they're down 02.
[Applause]
this is a fun trail
i tell you what i felt on top of it this
round i like this part right here
sped through that it's all good
coming around this corner felt great too
and just like that i finally
earned my spot here at race for the rail
i got fourth place out of 12
with only dom body and dave beating my
time of two minutes and 10 seconds
not gonna lie i feel really vindicated
after that race i mean
i was feeling like i didn't deserve to
be here at all let alone placing a
really good time
so at this point i don't even care how
the final race goes i
i feel so proud about how i did today
are you kidding me
this has been a crazy three days here
team delirium coming away
and sweeping all three team challenge
events of the team portion
race for the rail 2020 starts right now
grab your popcorn
get the big screen started and let's get
this party going
well ted today we got the best riders
they're at the top of the mountain right
now
and uh one of them is gonna leave here
as the champion
the energy is high people are stoked and
i can't wait to watch this race go down
i think ren deserves to be here i think
he's proved that yesterday yeah
and this is his chance to show that he's
serious rider and i think
i expect to come out and do that so i'm
going to be going head-to-head with dom
with angel and with brendan everyone is
expecting dom to win here so honestly
i'm just racing for second place
brandon is a fantastic rider i ride with
him all the time down in l.a
it almost feels like fate i'm glad we're
going first
as long as dom goes down we can both go
up dude i'd be happy with that yeah
nice little twist again go celebrate
until you cross those arches yeah
yeah yeah do a triple nuts
[Music]
yeah one at a time dude
this course has some familiar stuff some
new stuff and all of its sketch i was
definitely nervous going into the final
race for the rail it's the big televised
event
everyone's tuning in all my friends are
watching yeah we have a full broadcast
here we have 12 camera switch feed with
wireless
it's it's gonna be a good time first
round we have dom williams
angel cooper brandon schermeier and ren
wykman
and they're off oh my gosh dom is in the
lead position
let's see we got dom it looks like we
got brendan schermeier and then it looks
like we got ren and angel in the back
it's top three kind of separating top
two it looks like it's dom and brandon
shermeyer
here we see angel cooper in the rear
let's see if ren could put himself back
in position
i was right behind them but the problem
is that their dust was making it really
hard to see the ground
and i tried my best to keep up but then
sure enough i got stuck in a bit of a
chunky spot
and i knew the moment i jumped off it
was over there was no way i was gonna be
able to recover from that
oh my god brandon sure my coming around
aka floaty mcfly look at this pack yes
oh my gosh dom off his board brandon
shermeyer is in the lead let's see if
dom can catch him
wren wikeman is in third blasted by us
he's still ripping
wow holy smokes brendan schermeier if he
can hold dom
off he may finish this race first
are you kidding me ladies and gentlemen
i'm here with heat one winner
brendan schermeier dude boy this whole
race day today was filled with upsets
everyone was expecting dom to win
but brendan came through and overtook
him twice to win his heats
round two is filled with people we
didn't quite expect everyone expected
dom to be there
everyone expected body to be there but
jamie to win his heat and be there as
well
that was cool jeff was able to get a
huge lead right out of the gate but
jeff did go down really hard flying into
frame with crazy style but it did cost
him the race and he ended up not making
it past that heat
this would be an insane upset right here
brendan shermeyer
from los angeles california looking over
his shoulder
and he is going to the next round don
williams is out of the race head
and nobody saw this coming total
domination baby let's go
and it looks like dave stewart is
punching his ticket to the finals
with brandon schermeier all these upsets
led to the final round we have my friend
brendan against my new friend dave
tahoe dave and brandon schwermeyer it's
all smiles at the top out of this start
it's neck and neck you've got to say
todd hayes a little bit ahead of brendan
schermeyer
brand sherman are hot on his trail you
don't want to fall right behind because
of that dust
body harrison ran to that already tahoe
dave blasting down there and brendan
schermeier
right on his tail we are in the finals
folks one of the two of these riders
is gonna be crowned champion walk home
today with five thousand dollars in the
bank
they gotta stay on their boards here ted
we've seen people fall in this stretch
before
what a tight race we have so far dave
cut him off
dave come off that's a veteran move
brendan is going for a pass
brandon is passing back he's passing out
oh my god
oh my god floaty that lead oh my god i
don't think dave can come back from that
now
that's a huge lead he's into this gravel
straight
brandon is into the gravel straights
onto the single track he is in control
gets onto the grass if he doesn't mess
up if he doesn't crash
are they coming here let's go let's go
let's go oh my gosh all right guys
let's get this let's go
y'all flooded
[Music]
[Applause]
of los angeles california is taking home
the 2020
race the rail championship oh my
goodness
floaty just won brendan just won race
for the rail
[Applause]
even though our team didn't win i am so
beyond happy for brennan here
this is so cool no one expected brendan
to win he was a wild card he wasn't even
selected to come
and here he is with the grand champion
nunchucks
oh my god oh my god
what an incredible race what an amazing
event huge congrats
to brandon floaty mcfly on instagram
give him a follow he deserves it
he's the world champ after all huge
thank you to future motion for throwing
on
this amazing event i feel so special to
have been part of it
and if you want to see more about this
race and even greater detail future
motion has an hour-long documentary
about this race on their youtube channel
link in the description check it out if
you're interested
to all the other writers i'm glad to
call you guys friends now see you next
year because you know what
i have been training non-stop since the
end of this race before next year
i will see you then until then though
subscribe to quarter crew hit that like
button and maybe you'll see us
turning our friends heads into ice cubes
my head yeah your head no